[Musica]
ma il 2020 le nostre vite sono cambiate
la voce del mondo è rimasta muta per lo
shock per la paura di un nemico
inaspettato invisibile per il grande
dolore però com'è nella natura delle
cose dell'uomo la musica esplosa
sfidando la paura che era entrata nelle
nostre vite dandoci coraggio e
mostrandoci una capacità di resilienza
che non avremmo mai immaginato di avere
noi tutti ci ricordiamo delle persone
cantare sui tetti improvvisare
spettacoli musicali o dj set sui balconi
di tante città italiane e tante città
d'europa
quello è stato un modo efficace per
ristabilire delle connessioni attraverso
la musica nel momento del peggiore
isolamento guardare ascoltare è unirmi
alle serenate di tante persone musicisti
o no a me sconosciute sui tetti di roma
a pochi metri da casa mia
insieme al profondo legame con la musica
che da sempre accompagna la mia vita è
stata una delle scintille che ha portato
a questo progetto progetto che si è
concretizzato quando sono arrivata qui a
madrid come nuovo direttore
dell'istituto italiano di cultura
questo palazzo palacio rea brandt es
da secoli appartiene alla vita culturale
della città di madrid e da quasi un
secolo come sede dell'istituto aliano di
cultura accoglie musicisti scrittori
intellettuali di eccellenza offrendosi
come palcoscenico per un incredibile
incontro tra culture tra italia e spagna
durante la pandemia questo teatro è
rimasto in silenzio
tutto si è fermato la mia la nostra
missione doveva essere far sì che questo
teatro potesse tornare a risuonare di
cultura riempendo quel silenzio
assordante con la bellezza e con il
potere della musica cosa e come fare
la mobilità delle persone era
estremamente ridotta prendere aerei un
rischio e noi volevamo che questo teatro
assolutamente fosse il protagonista di
qualcosa di nuovo per dare stimolo non
solo a noi ma anche musicisti stanchi e
frustrati dopo mesi di concerti in
streaming
dovevamo farci venire assolutamente
un'idea per continuare a fare il nostro
lavoro che è quello di sostenere e fare
cultura la musica però unisce la musica
connette ecco la soluzione
immaginate un musicista spagnolo su una
re qui in questo teatro facendo tornare
a suonare questo fantastico pianoforte
immaginate magari una cantante italiana
su una terrazza di una splendida città
italiana che interpreta le sue canzoni
i due non si conoscono ma hanno qualcosa
di straordinario un comune
l'eccezionale talento la curiosità la
voglia e il desiderio di tornare a
suonare
noi abbiamo deciso di farle suonare
insieme
così a distanza ciascuno nel proprio
ambiente e di farli incontrare nel web
in fondo la musica fa già di per sé
risuonare a distanza è un fenomeno
acustico quello della vibrazione per
simpatia corde lontane risuonano insieme
se trovano la giusta frequenza d'onda
abbiamo deciso di applicare sperimentare
questa formula a quattro diversi generi
musicali
volevamo creare un nuovo ciclo di
concerti con quattro appuntamenti per
ricreare un dialogo ideale tra italia
spagna attraverso la cultura definita
l'idea ci siamo messi al lavoro
il musicista spagnolo doveva venire qui
in questo teatro è una troupe lo avrebbe
registrato specularmente una truffa
avrebbe registrato il musicista italiano
magari in una location suggestiva in
modo da creare un gemellaggio perfetto
con il nostro bellissimo teatro in fase
di post produzione
avremmo poi garantito la massima qualità
del prodotto audio la sincronizzazione
con le immagini scegliendo quelle
inquadrature che potevano maggiormente
avvicinare lo spettatore agli artisti
quindi offrendo dei dettagli che non
avrebbero potuto avere in un concerto
dal vivo
avevamo chiaro quindi che la tecnologia
era sì importante però non doveva essere
la finalità del nostro progetto doveva
essere solo un mezzo
la vera sfida doveva essere quella di
trovare gli artisti giusti che potessero
essere coinvolti e lavorare con noi
il suo progetto in fondo ci siamo
sentiti un po come gli artefici di
appuntamenti al buio e come ogni
tentativo di match making dovevamo
quindi trovare degli artisti che
avessero uno stile inconfondibile ma che
allo stesso tempo fossero i curiosi
flessibili e aperti ad altre forme di
sperimentazione all'incontro musicale
ci siamo quindi divertiti a cercare ea
creare delle combinazioni ascoltando
diversi musicisti nel ricchissimo
panorama musicale italiano spagnolo ne
abbiamo capito le sensibilità e abbiamo
quindi pensato alle migliori
combinazioni almeno secondo noi abbiamo
contattato gli artisti e la loro prima
reazione è stata quella di un po di
scetticismo ma allo stesso tempo di
grande entusiasmo per cui siamo riusciti
in breve tempo a portarli nella nostra
squadra
come ogni poi appuntamento al buio il
piena regola
i musicisti non potevano fare prove
potevano solo accordarsi sul repertorio
il resto doveva essere creazione pur
potendo quindi così provare
quell'adrenalina l'adrenalina del primo
incontro che caratterizza una
performance vivo e che la rende davvero
unica eravamo quindi consapevoli di una
cosa che questo progetto potrà essere o
un grandissimo disastro
ho un grandissimo successo e con questa
consapevolezza
grazie alla collaborazione di un'agenzia
di produzione siamo quindi partiti con
il nostro progetto la nostra avventura
con il primo concerto abbiamo reso uno
splendido omaggio alla canzone d'autore
italiana e internazionale
il duo musica nuda composto da petra
magoni e ferruccio spinetti sia unito al
piano jazz flamenco di ciano domínguez
dando vita a una combinazione davvero
straordinaria
ero qui in questo teatro con ciano che
suonava proprio quel pianoforte e gli
sono bastati pochissimi minuti per
entrare in perfetta sintonia con la
musica di petra e ferruccio quando ho
ascoltato la traccia audio sono rimasta
davvero sorpresa per la bellezza del
risultato ma sono rimasta ancora più
sorpresa quando ho visto le immagini
montate perfettamente sincronizzate con
l'audio perché questo prodotto era non
solo bello da ascoltare ma anche molto
bello da vedere
eravamo quindi riusciti a catturare le
emozioni che musicisti provano quando
suonano ea trasmettere quel intangibile
energia al di là dello schermo oltre i
limiti di una piattaforma streaming
avevamo quindi il nostro primo concerto
virtuale
siamo andati avanti con il jazz e il
trombone di gianluca petrella da torino
si è unito al perfettamente alle armonie
del pianoforte di marco me scheda in un
certo senso la vita come il jazz diceva
george gershwin e meglio quando si
improvvisa e in fondo questa era anche
la filosofia del nostro progetto ma non
si poteva sposare assolutamente con la
filosofia di un musicista classico
all'organizzazione quelli del terzo
concerto ci siamo dovuti confrontare con
una nuova difficoltà non tanto il
montaggio non tanto l'aspetto tecnico
quanto la resistenza o meno lo
scetticismo dei musicisti che pensavano
che questo nuovo mezzo non potesse
esprimere a pieno il loro lavoro e la
loro qualità
questo perché nella musica classica
l'improvvisazione si ricorre molto poco
all'improvvisazione e la perfezione
viene dopo tante tante prove che portano
i musicisti addirittura a respirare
nello stesso momento
in perfetta sintonia stavamo chiedendo
quindi ai nostri musicisti di fare
qualcosa e quali non erano abituati e
che secondo loro secondo la loro
esperienza poteva non portare ad un
ottima qualità del prodotto io stessa
da musicista di formazione classica sono
quindi dovuta ricorrere a tutte le mie
capacità di persuasione per convincere
gli artisti a provare a fare un
tentativo ea garantire in qualche modo
il risultato ma io stessa avevo un unica
certezza è l'unica certezza era lo
straordinario talento e la
professionalità dei musicisti che
avevamo scelto marta rossi e la ritirata
ma risultato è stato straordinario
siamo riusciti a creare ea dare un
bellissimo omaggio all'italia la spagna
attraverso la musica di musicisti per
barocco con vivaldi con boccherini
creando un gemellaggio ideale per questo
bellissimo teatro è un altro tempio del
barocco il palazzo barberini
ma e musicisti alla fine del risultato
erano particolarmente contenti ed è una
grande cosa dirlo perché in genere
musicisti sono molto critici e
soprattutto molto auto critici con il
concerto numero 4 abbiamo deciso di
rendere le cose ancora più difficili di
sperimentare qualcosa di assolutamente
nuovo di unire quindi un linguaggio
contemporaneo della musica elettronica
con la danza nazionale spagnola il
flamenco una cosa mai fatta prima
anche qui la chiave del successo sono
state da un lato la nostra giusta
intuizione ma soprattutto dall'altro la
straordinarietà l'eccezionale talento
degli artisti che avevamo scelto
affascinato dalle immagini di rocío
molina provviste sul web calab
un musicista e produttore italiano ha
composto un pezzo davvero avvolgente con
un ritmo ha via via crescente su questo
prezzo rosolino ha costruito una
coreografia di grandissima intensità e
davvero incredibile
caleb è rimasto sorpreso nel vedere
risultato ma non avrebbe mai immaginato
di poter contare anche su un altro
strumento le percussioni dei piedi e
delle mani di rosia
siamo quindi riusciti a creare un
qualcosa di assolutamente nuovo
tradizione e modernità si sono unite
abbiamo fatto dialogare linguaggi
diversi e questo teatro si è trasformato
nuovamente in una sala da ballo così
come è stato pertanto i secoli come
palacio de avanti e vibranti attivisti
cultura di musica e di vita
questa è la storia di un'idea semplice e
folla allo stesso tempo che con tanta
passione creatività e divertimento si è
trasformata in realtà non abbiamo voluto
creare un prodotto in sostituzione del
concerto dal vivo
quella è un'emozione che sia per gli
artisti che per il pubblico è davvero
insostituibile unica e speriamo di
potervi tornare presto in massima
serenità quello che abbiamo voluto fare
e quindi creare un qualcosa di
assolutamente nuovo diverso dallo
streaming pura e semplice
e dando l'idea quindi è una nuova forma
di creazione artistica a distanza ci
piace pensare a questa immagine immagini
della musica che parte dall'italia o
specularmente dalla spagna risuona
passando i confini attraversa come uno
specchio per riscoprirsi ancora una
volta musica
abbiamo capito quindi abbiamo dimostrato
in questo modo che attraverso la musica
le connessioni digitali sono anche
possibili e ora se vi va possiamo anche
cominciare il nostro concerto numero 5
insieme
[Musica]
questa è la mia introduzione
vi aspettiamo sul web per continuare
insieme